♪♪
.
>> Sean: ALRIGHT SO MUCH
HAPPENING AROUND THE GLOBE.
JOINING US NOW SECRETARY OF
STATE MIKE POMPEO, ALWAYS GOOD
TO SEE YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US
>>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
THANK YOU SEAN, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME ON TONIGHT.
>> Sean: HERE IS VENEZUELA WITH
ONE OF THE LARGEST OIL REVEFSHS
IN THE WORLD.
80% HYPER INFLATION, POVERTY,
BARE NECESSITIES, CHAOS, TWO
PRESIDENTS AT ONCE, IF YOU WILL.
WHAT IS THE SITUATION AND
OBVIOUSLY YOUR POSITION, THE
PRESIDENT'S POSITION IS VERY
IMPORTANT HERE
>>> SO THE PRESIDENT HAD A
CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH PRESIDENT
WAY DOE TODAY, THE QUEST FOR
FREEDOM IS ON.
THE VENEZUELAN PEOPLE MADE IT
CLEAR THAT THEY DEMAND HE NOT BE
THE PRESIDENT AND THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES IS HERE TO
SUPPORT FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY.
THIS WAS A ONCE WEALTHY NATION
WITH EE MORM NOW NATIONAL
RESOURCES.
WE HAVE A HUMANITARIAN
CHALLENGE, THIS IS A MAN MADE
CATASTROPHE AND WE'RE INTENT
ABOUT HELPING THE VENEZUELIAN
PEOPLE CORRECT IT.
>> Sean: THERE'S STOCK ABOUT A
SECOND SUMMIT WITH KIM JONG-UN.
IT'S AMAZING TO ME, NO MORE
ROCKETS HAPPENING, BEING FIRED
OVER JAPAN, THREATENING THE
ENTIRE REGION AND THE UNITED
STATES.
HOSTAGES HAVE BEEN RETURNED, THE
REMAINS OF AMERICAN SOLDIERS
HAVE BEEN RETURNED AND DEE
NUCLEARRATION TALKS RETURN.
WHAT DO YOU FORESEE ANOTHER
SUMMIT?
>>> SEAN I THINK WE'LL HAVE A
SUMMIT AT THE END OF THE MONTH.
THAT'S THE PLAN.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'VE AGREED TO
AND WE'VE AGREED TO AS WELL.
WE'LL DO IT SOME PLACE IN ASIA.
SO I THINK THAT LOOKS GOOD.
I AM DISPATCHING A TEAM THERE,
HEADED THAT WAY FOR AN
ADDITIONAL STEP TOWARD THE PATH
FOR NOT ONLY DEE NUKE SAYING OF
THE PENINSULA BUT A BRIGHTER
FUTURE AND SECURITY IN A WAY NO
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
ABLE TO ACHIEVE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ABLE TO
CONVINCE CHAIRMAN KIM THAT IT'S
TIME FOR MY TEAM AND ALL OF THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT TO WORK
AND DELIVER ON OUR COMMITMENT TO
END IT IN THE PENINSULA.
HE'S TOLD US HE'S PREPARED.
>> Sean: AS THE FORMER DIRECTOR
OF THE CI A, I WOULD ARGUE THAT
INTELLIGENCE GATHERING IS MORE
OF AN ART THAN A SCIENCE,
ALTHOUGH SOME THINGS ARE
CERTAIN.
AS RELATES TO INTELLIGENCE,
INTERPRETATIONS OF IRANIAN
CAPABILITIES, YOU HAVE THE
PRESIDENT AND PRIME MINISTER
NETANYAHU MAYBE DISAGREEING WITH
THE INTELLIGENCE REPORTS.
I WOULD CHALK THAT UP TO
INTERPRETATION BUT I'M GUESSING.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>>> YEAH I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S MUCH
DISPUTE.
HAVING HAD A CHANCE TO BE THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CI A, I THINK
THE INTELLIGENCE SUPPORTS THAT
IRAN IS A RISK.
THEY HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO
ENRICH NUCLEAR MATERIAL, THEY
HAVE INCREASE
HAVE INCREASING CAPACITIES TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS
IMPROVING THEIR MISSILE PROGRAM.
IT WAS JUST LAST WEEK THEY
ATTEMPTED TO LAUNCH A SPACE
LAUNCH VEHICLE WHICH CERTAINLY
WOULD HELP THEM DELIVER ON THEIR
MISSILE PROGRAM.
THESE ARE ALL COMPONENTS THAT
LEAD US TO A PLACE WHERE THEY
COULD HAVE A SYSTEM THAT
THREATENS AMERICA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS MADE CLEAR
WE'RE NOT GOING TO TOLERATE IT.
WE HAVE A SET OF POLICIES IN
PLACE TO PREVENT THAT.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION ABOUT
SYRIA, AFGHANISTAN, AMERICAN
TROOPS.
SOME MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND
MEMBERS IN THE SENATE HAVE
DISAGREEMENT.
IS THERE A SOLUTION AND WHAT IS
THE REAL STATUS OF ISIS?
IS IT DID HE GO GRADED TO THE
POINT WHERE IT'S NOT ANYWHERE
NEAR THE THREAT IT ONCE WAS?
>>> WELL THE PRESIDENT WILL MAKE
A SIGNIFICANT ANNOUNCEMENT I
THINK IN THE STATE OF THE UNION
NEXT WEEK WITH RESPECT TO THE
STATUS OF THE CALIPHATE, THE
REAL ESTATE, THE GROUNDS FROM
WHICH ISIS HAD BEEN OPERATING
WHEN THIS ADMINISTRATION CAME
IN.
YOU REMEMBER PRISONERS IN CAGES,
PEOPLE KNEELING ON THE BEACHES
AND BEING BEHEADED.
THIS WAS TRAGIC.
WE ALSO KNOW IN SPITE OF
ENORMOUS PROGRESS AND SUCCESS
THAT THE THREAT FROM RADICAL
ISLAMIC TERRORISM IS WELL.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THERE'S NOT
A RE-INJURY GENES OF ISIS.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED
TO THAT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS MADE CLEAR
IT IS A PRIORITY FOR HIM.
AND AS THE SECRETARY OF STATE I
CAN PROMISE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO ALL WE
CAN TO KEEP THEM SAFE FROM THIS
THREAT.
>> Sean: ONE THING I ALWAYS
REMEMBERED IN THE 9/11
COMMISSION REPORT THEY WERE AT
WAR WITH US, WE WEREN'T AT WAR
WITH THEM.
AND WE KNOW THAT THOSE RADICALS
ARE OUT THERE AND WHAT THEIR